bonsoir merci d'avoir dit sublime fait
cool j'aime bien marcher comme ça c'est
rare d'être habillée comme ça c'est ça
serra bravo à del bravo ma petite adèle
je voulais vous parler d'une chose qui
me vint il ya un malaise en ce moment
qui agitent notre belle démocratie
française
je voudrais vous parler un peu de la
montée de l'antisémitisme
non je rigole en ohio zi au nom au bout
at elle pas sympa on était bien on
s'amusait appuie toi que nous embête de
le ferai plus non plus sérieusement vous
vous avez sûrement entendu dire qu'on
enseigne aurait désormais la théorie du
film de genre dans des écoles de cinéma
français c'est faux et je rassure aussi
tous les membres de l'académie qui
aurait reçu un sms où il sera question
de cours de masturbation intellectuelle
dans des groupes de films d'auteurs
français c'est absolument faux et c'est
une rumeur
alain guiraudie et abdellatif kechiche
ont prouvé que la masturbation dans le
film d'auteur français n'était pas
seulement intellectuelle
nous ne voulons pas de hiérarchie entre
les jambes ne voulons pas de hiérarchie
entre les sexes nous ne voulons pas de
hiérarchie entre les rôles